[Music]
mike is in orange county california hey
mike how are you
hi dave hi dr d i hope you guys are
sitting down because this is probably
going to make your head hurt um bring it
let's start the hour out with that hold
our beers mike let's do this a brief
background i'm a twin i was adopted at
birth to a wonderful family
about 20 years ago i researched my birth
family and made connections my
twin had no interest at all in
connecting with the family i've
developed a relationship with
the existing family which was my birth
mother a half brother and a birth uncle
my birth mother and uncle have been
vacant from the family since i joined
the family my uncle
passed away a week ago
and i just learned that i was the
executor of his my wife and i are the
executor of his trust
and his he left us his condo
which is old skin needs some work
but we're navigating one financially do
we keep the condo rent it
and or do we sell it how much work do we
put into it and secondly
i'm already getting calls from my birth
mother and uh half brother
claiming that they're entitled to the
property and
my half brother already said that i need
to fire sell it and send him a hundred
thousand dollars immediately
my uncle's wishes he clearly
communicated to me and his character
picker that he didn't want them having
anything to the point where i asked him
about a antique picture and he said if
arlene takes it uh she would only sell
the frame
um so she he feel feels strongly that
they have both stolen from him over the
years so i'm trying to navigate the uh
relationship that's his sister and his
nephew
correct okay and uh he didn't have a
sibling or children
he was never married uh no children okay
and uh did he have a written will
he's got a written will and a trust
leaving me as the executor of the trust
and leaving
my wife and i
everything except for his car and a
small savings account that he wants to
go to his um
uh caretaker yeah
okay
well i'm so sorry what a pinch to put
you in after all the weirdness of this
whole thing
so how is your relationship before all
this happened with your half brother and
your birth mom
uh
intermittent um
she had violated a number of um
boundaries that we had set um
just to give you a feel for it so she
has she has her own issues
she's got plenty of issues
um
how ironic that your relationship ends
up being with your
uncle
that you also didn't know
that's ironic
but he was i mean he was lonely uh he
was he was closer than her he's just a
die-hard sweet man he worked for a
toyota dealership for 46 years working
on their lot he's just just a blue
collar
sweet guy that i developed a
relationship with so mike here's a
here's a common
situation here
is you
really hanging on to this is hard what
i'm about to say okay
hanging on to a fantasy
a myth
that somehow this
relationship with your birth mother is
going to be restored to what it should
have been
or what it could have been
same with your no same with your
happiness
not at all okay okay i am more concerned
about
that you allow into your head is a
choice you're making
okay okay
do you have no moral
or legal obligation to give either one
of them a dime in fact i would suggest
based on what your uncle looked you in
the eye and told you
you would be violating his wishes by so
here's what i hear here's my answer if
i'm you to your half brother to your mom
and just go this is really awkward for
all of us i love you guys and i'm really
sorry we're in this situation
here's my legal
obligation
i am the executor of the estate which
means i am legally bound
to execute
to follow through on
the written
wishes
of your uncle your brother
i don't have a choice i have to do what
that says
or i am liable
for legal action
that's why they call it an executor
because a a mic an executor executes
the terms of the will that's all they do
they don't get to make up
new wills they don't get to change the
deal
they just have to do what the deal says
that's the law mike
you don't have a choice now once you
have executed
your uncle's wishes
which happens to be in this case that
you become the owner of all of these
things
if you choose to give away your stuff
then that's you
choosing to give away your stuff but if
you give away your stuff to someone who
is demanding it in order to give them
in order to create a relationship hint
hint there was never a relationship to
start with relationships that are based
on a financial transaction are called
prostitution
and so if the only way your brother or
half brother is ever going to speak to
you again is if you give him your money
he's opting out he's all he's checked
out same thing with uh
arlene or whatever her name was but yeah
i i it but that doesn't make this easier
that is just the correct thing to do
but people that function like your
birth mom and your half brother
are they are guilt they're they're
travel agents for guilt trips
they feel entitled to other people's
stuff
so if i choose to leave all of my money
to one kid
and the other two kids get nothing
it was my money
they are not entitled
not even legally entitled if i have a
will that says they don't get it
you know if i look at one of my two ki
my one of my three kids go heroin addict
i am not funding your
addiction your death
uh you get zippo because you have zippo
character
and i put that in the will
he's got no moral rights no spiritual
rights no legal rights
and by the way that would have been an
act of love
because your uncle looked at her and
said money is not a blessing to this
lady when she gets it she misbehaves
with it it's a curse so i'm not gonna
bother her with the curse
sorry mike it's hard to go through what
you're going through i hate it for you
but that you know i would just bad guy
off your uncle and go gosh i'm i'm kind
of handcuffed here i'm just the executor
i don't have any legal choices i have to
do
what the will says
and i don't sorry if you get you want to
be mad go go out the graveyard and yell
at the tombstone
because i'm not here i can't do anything
about this
but it's not going to end well nope
these two goobs are going to be goobs
because they're goobs